Hi.
Welcome, everyone.
We were so thrilled to have
such a wonderful turnout
for this session.
And I just want to
welcome you all to it
and thank you for
the active engagement
that we're going to
be asking of you.
So don't get too
comfy in the seat
that you're sitting
in because there's
going to be some true
breaking out happening here.
I'm Rebecca Nesson.
I work at the Extension
School and summer school,
and, together with Erin
Bauman from the Kennedy School
and my colleagues
Adrian and Karena,
we have planned
this session to help
take us from the big picture
of thinking about teaching
evaluation that we
had in the plenary
down to the smaller
picture of focusing
on a single course, perhaps
a course that you teach
or a course that
you've worked on,
and thinking about
how the teaching
and learning in that
particular course
might be improved
without overhauling
the entire syllabus,
without changing
the fundamental style of who
the teacher is as a teacher.
So we're looking at smaller
types of interventions
that can make a big
difference in the experience
of the teacher and the
students in the course.
And we started with a
couple of hypotheses
of the types of these
changes in courses
that we've seen
make big differences
in our experiences working in
teaching and learning centers.
So first, changes that help us
to create engagement to make
sure that the students minds
are focused on what's happening
in the classroom while
they're in the class
and actively engaging
with the material,
and, also, when they're working
on activities outside of class.
Secondly, building
trust within the class,
forming a sense of
community and relationships
between the instructors and
between the peers in the class
so that the students really
are comfortable and open enough
to be ready for the learning
and the learning experience
that we're hoping to
create in the class.
And then, thirdly,
to provide students
with the tools they need
to actually assimilate what
they're learning in the
class or to help them
focus on the right pieces of--
the right concepts that
you want them to take away,
and to think hard
about those things.
So to help us do
this we have invited
two distinguished faculty
members to give us
two brief talks about their
experiences with activities
that they have designed
that are along these lines
and that have made
transformations
in their own class.
So we have Emily Click, from
the Harvard Divinity School
and Jonathan Haussmann,
from the Harvard Medical
School, who are going to share
with us their experiences.
After that, we are going to do
a larger activity where we all
move around the room,
and you'll get a chance
to play with these mysterious
decks of cards that
are sitting in front of you.
But we're going to start off
with creating our own community
for this session with a
little icebreaker of our own.
So for that, I'm going
to pass it on to Aaron.
So for this it's kind of
going to try and channel
some of the
exercises that we may
have done in primary school.
So I'd like, at your
tables, for everyone
to count off 1, 2, and 3.
So here-- skipping
Jonathan and Emily--
we will go 1, 2, 3.
And then 1.
So just do that at your tables.
Everybody count 1, 2, 3.
And then we'll break out.
Don't worry.
Now that it sounds like
everybody has a number,
I'd like everyone who
is a 1 to come and sit
at one of these three
tables, everyone who is a 2
to come in at one of these
three tables, and everyone's a 3
to come and sit at
these three tables.
All right, another one of my--
another one of my regulatory
primary school tricks.
Now that everybody has
gotten to their new tables
and put themselves
up in new groups,
we're going to give you a
chance to go back and do
what it sounds like you
are already starting to do,
and that's get to know one
another at these new groups.
So at your new tables, if
you want to group yourself
into groups of kind
of three or four--
so it doesn't have to go on the
whole group, but just groups
of three to four.
I would like you to take kind
of the next five to 10 minutes
and share your name,
share your role--
where you're from, what you do--
and then share a problem or
an opportunity for improvement
that you have encountered
in a course you're teaching,
a course you're taking, or
a course you're working on.
So name, role, and a
problem or opportunity
for improvement in a course
that you're teaching, taking,
or working on.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
All right.
So now that you've all
had a chance to get
to know one another
a little bit better,
and to kind of think about
some of the teaching challenges
that you're bringing
in with you,
I would like to invite Emily
Click from the Harvard Divinity
School, up to share some of
her teaching practices with us
and, specifically, to talk
about her practice using
the classroom contract.
So it's great to be with you.
I'm looking forward to
learning from all of you.
And let me just
begin by asking you
to think for a minute
about a particular class
or a classroom-type
environment where you function.
And if you could think of a
one-word adjective for what
you hope will characterize
that learning environment.
What would it be like,
in one adjective?
So anybody got it?
We've got to have extreme
extroverts answered this,
but some people are like me.
Anybody got one?
Yes.
Stimulating.
Aha, anything else?
Nimble.
Aha?
Exciting.
Yes.
Engaged.
That's actually my word as well.
So you get 1,000 points.
Can somebody put
that on the board?
So none of us said
passive, right?
It's not what we
dream of, but that
often is what winds up
happening in our classroom.
So I wanted to just give
you a a bit of a story,
and then just some of the
nuts and bolts of what
I'm doing with what she was
calling a classroom contract
or the language of
public agreement.
So this story that
I have to tell
is not a very attractive
story about myself,
which is that, about seven
years ago, as I was teaching,
I began to realize
that students had
their expensive laptops open.
And we usually,
in the Div school,
have a kind of
square of students.
And the students whose
screens I could not see,
someone reported to me
were posting on Facebook
and were checking their
email and so forth.
And boy, did I get my nose
out of joint about that.
You know, it was a--
well, you know, how
could they be doing that?
They're not focusing,
they're not learning.
Very insulted and so forth.
You know, after a
while, I realized oh,
that's about my ego, isn't it?
I began to get a little bit
of a sense of humor about it.
Where I really got
the sense of humor
about it was when I was sitting
in an administrative meeting
where somebody was
making a presentation
and I had my very expensive
Harvard-paid-for laptop open,
and I looked at my
screen and realized
I was checking my email.
And I thought, well,
isn't that interesting?
I'm getting insulted when
the students are doing that,
and I'm doing exactly
the same thing.
Maybe it's a
legitimate thing to do.
I don't know.
But if it is a problem, to
whom does the problem belong?
And I realize it
doesn't actually
belong to me, except for
my ego getting bruised.
But apart from that, it really
belongs to the students.
And following Ron
Heifetz advice,
you give the problem
to the people
to whom the problem belongs.
So this led me into the Kegan--
Robert Keegan and
Lisa Laskow Lahey
stuff on creating a language
of public agreement.
And so I started doing this.
And let me just
tell you, if you get
tempted to do it after I told
my story, when I first did it,
it felt just like when
you're standing on a cliff
and you're a little too
high above the water.
And as you know,
the water's cold,
and you're going
to jump off anyway.
That's kind of how
it felt. Because it
was very vulnerable to start
asking the students what kind
of learning environment
they wanted to have,
including the use of computers.
Because, of course, I
knew the right answer
was that they shouldn't
be doing things
like posting on
Facebook and so forth.
But instead of me
giving the answer,
to have that engaged
classroom, they
get to create the
learning environment that
will work for them.
So I started having this
thing-- and I actually
did this yesterday
with my class.
So it was the third
week of school.
Obviously, you can't
do a shopping week,
and the second week is
still all this logistics.
But very early on I spent an
hour with the students saying,
what do you want to
do about computer use?
It does a couple of things.
One is it pops a hole in the
balloon of you're pretending
you're not doing that and I'm
pretending that I don't notice
that you're doing that.
So that we can be real
with each other, which
is a part of being truly
engaged in the classroom,
bringing your full real self.
It also has happened that
students have helped each other
to understand that
they get distracted
when they're sitting
next to somebody
who is doing Instagram.
And it's far more
powerful if they
hear from their peers
what the effect of actions
is than if they--
than if I impose
some kind of rule.
So that's one of the
areas that we discuss.
Another area that I
lead them in discussing
is what do you do if you
have not prepared for class.
And I let them decide
what do you do.
OK.
So this just turns out
to be far more effective
than the professor saying I
want you to read everything
before class, because we
all know that people--
the record on how much people
read as is abysmal, right?
So I feel like
it's my job to make
what happens in class such
an exciting exercise that
pulls on the
readings and they're
working with their peers
that, if they haven't read,
they're at a disadvantage
to enjoy and have fun
with their peers-- or not
just fun, but, you know,
deep learning experience
with regard to the material.
That's my job.
But they need to
decide, do you still
come when you're not prepared?
Again, is poking a giant hole
in the balloon of students
pretending that they're
fully prepared and professors
pretending that they don't know.
Because, of course,
if you've taught
the material for a while, you
know in a second if somebody
has not read it.
But you're supposed to pretend
like you don't realize that.
So what I now have, often, is--
they decide how are they
supposed to identify
if they have not prepared.
And sometimes, an
under-prepared student
can be an advantage if
you leverage it correctly.
So if you put the under-prepared
student in a small group
with other students
who are prepared,
the prepared students then
take on the role of teacher,
and they get to learn
the material more deeply.
Does that make some sense?
So it doesn't have to
be a lose for everybody
when the inevitable happens.
So a couple of other
areas we discuss.
One is confidentiality.
As you can imagine,
at the Div school,
sometimes the material
gets very personal.
And I think that's also true
in many of your classrooms
as well.
And so, what are you supposed
to do if something is shared
that's very personal?
Are you allowed to talk
about it when you go home,
or with other people
at the Div school?
And so forth.
And then the fourth area
is a very significant one.
And the way I
usually phrase it is,
what do you do if the teacher
says something that's racist?
Like, as in me, you know.
I just, again, poke a giant
hole in my wish and desire
to never make mistakes.
And I still have that desire,
and I still feel awful
when I do make mistakes.
I decided a long
time ago I did not
want to read on teaching
evaluations in July
that I stepped on
somebody in February.
You know?
This is just no fun for anybody.
And it also damages the learning
environment so crucially
when actions or words do
harm, either by the professor
or other students.
So instead of pretending, again,
like this will never happen,
which then, of
course, shuts down
the people who do get harmed by
such harmful speech or actions,
I set it up that this
may happen, especially
when we're talking about things
that matter a great deal, what
do we do about it.
Now, in all of these
areas that we discuss--
and there's more than
I'm listing right now--
part of the point is to
have a clear agreement
about what the norms
are for the classroom.
More to the point
is to have a norm
for what you do when the
norms are violated and broken.
If you don't have
this discussion,
then any-- everybody
has in their minds
what the norms should be.
But it's different.
So when you've had
that discussion,
you have a way to
capture the learning that
can come about in these
moments of difficulty.
And most importantly, this
surfaces-- and I think today,
overall, is supposed to
be about evaluation--
my own deep conviction that,
while teachers and professors
have a huge amount of
responsibility for what happens
in the classroom, I don't--
I don't abdicate my
responsibility one bit.
So I tell the students,
I'm still bossy, you know.
But I'm not the only person
responsible for the learning
that's going on
in the classroom.
And it is so awesome.
I said it was like being
on the edge of a cliff.
Let me tell you, when
you jump into that pool,
you find out how trustworthy
those students are,
how impressive they are,
what leaders they can be,
and how beautiful it is to see
them build learning community.
But all of your
students are as well.
That's what the
work is that follows
the educational experience.
So I like to give them a real
time experience of how hard it
is to build community.
Do I have one more minute?
Or are we at the end?
So one-- I'll just tell
you really brief story.
One time, I had a
relatively small class,
and a couple of students
were taping the class,
and a couple of
other students felt
they didn't feel comfortable
to fully participate
because the class
was being taped.
Those who were taping were
English as a second language
learners.
So there were really legitimate
concerns on both sides.
So I engaged them in a
full discussion of it,
didn't get resolved.
Had another full discussion
of it, didn't get resolved.
I didn't resolve it.
Students got really,
really angry with me.
I got e-mails,
and, you know, this
is your job to resolve this.
In a little while later, I
was teaching the Ron Heifetz
material about the
flight to authority
when problems get
really difficult.
And as I was teaching
that, they went,
oh, that's what we were doing.
We were flying to you to
resolve things that you
were saying belong to us.
So that's it.
[APPLAUSE]
So I want to thank Emily for
sharing not only her story,
but also such a really
powerful teaching practice that
can help both in the area
of creating connections
and increasing engagement.
So thank you for that.
And now, I'd like to
invite Jonathan Hausmann,
from the Medical School, up
to share some of his teaching
practices with us.
Thank you for inviting me.
So I'm a rheumatologist.
And every year we go to
our national rheumatology
conference.
It's usually held
in fancy places,
like Chicago and San Diego.
And it's five days of
really intense break--
you know, breathtaking
lectures about all sorts
of different topics
in rheumatology.
And I remember one
time, several years ago,
after I came back, my
wife asked me how it went.
I said, great.
Then she asked me,
what did you learn?
And really, I sat
there for a while.
And I really didn't know what
to say because I didn't remember
much of the material
that was presented
during the conference.
And then I sort of--
that's when my interest
peaked about how we learn.
And I sort of started
doing some research
about cognitive
learning theories.
And I realized that lecturers--
sort of like what
I'm doing now--
are a lousy way for
people to learn, right?
So just by sitting there,
you're being very passive,
you're not doing any learning.
So it's not very effective.
Thankfully, I thought, OK,
good thing it's not just me,
it's the lectures.
So you know, I read a
lot about active learning
and how, really, we should
get rid of lectures.
And tons of
publications have shown
the benefit of active
learning for the learner.
But here I was in
my medical training.
Things weren't changing.
Right?
We still had grand rounds,
which was a lecture.
We had journal clubs,
which is a lecture.
We had case conference,
which is, usually, a lecture.
And all of my didactic
acts were still lectures.
So I said, OK, I can't
get rid of lectures.
So how can we make a
lecture more effective?
Well, there's a lot of
ways that professors can
make lectures more effective.
And sort of the tool that I
learned was through questions.
So we talked a little bit
about questions this morning
in the panel.
And really, the great thing
that I like about questions
is that they are a form
of retrieval practice.
OK?
So questions not only
assess whether you're
a learner actually
knows the material,
but it actually enhances
those neural connections
for that information
so that, next time
that they are asked that
question, they know it better.
So questions actually help
people learn and help people
retain that material
throughout their learning.
Like we said this
morning, it's not just
about how you do on
the test, but it's
how you remember that stuff
10 years down the road,
and how it affects your career.
So great.
So I found out that, if
the instructor provides
the audience with
questions at the beginning
of the presentation, that
can actually help to increase
curiosity throughout
the lecture, and makes
people learn things better.
I learned that if the lecture
provides an opportunity
for to ask questions in the
middle of the presentation,
and have students try
to apply the material
that they learned
in a new setting,
that that's also
effective for learning.
And then I learned that,
if the instructor provides
a short quiz after
the lecture, that also
helps to enhance learning,
and those students
do better on the tests
weeks or months later on.
OK.
That's great.
But still, my professors
weren't doing that.
All those good things that
the literature supported still
wasn't happening.
So I said, OK, that's great.
So what can I do
as a learner to try
to make those experiences
more effective?
And sort of what I stumbled
into the literature
was this idea of
learner-generated questions.
So learner-generated questions.
So these are questions that
the learner asks and answers
after any educational
experience.
So if it's a
lecture about lupus,
at the end of the lecture
I would think about, OK,
what was important
about this lecture?
How can they make
that into a question?
How can they answer
that question?
And the literature shows that
learner-generated questions
are as effective for learning as
instructor-generated questions.
So that's kind of cool.
What the literature also
says is that learn--
if you teach your learner to
generate their own questions,
for example, after a lecture,
it actually changes the way
that they see the lecture.
It actually-- it's sort of like
a metacognitive strategy that
can be employed, whereby
they are able to, as they
are listening to the lecture, to
start thinking about questions
and start answering
in their mind.
OK, this question came up.
Here's how I would answer it.
And the studies show that if
you teach them these skills,
they actually learn the
lecture material a lot better.
And same thing has been
shown after reading material.
So if you ask them
to read an article,
and ask them to generate
questions and answer
the questions after
the article, they
retain that material
much better.
OK.
So that was pretty cool.
So what I started doing during
my fellowship was just that.
So at the end of
every case conference,
journal club, grand rounds,
I would generate a question.
I would do a multiple choice
question with the answers.
And then I would start
sending it to my co Fellows.
And they kind of like it,
and they got really engaged.
And I noticed that they became
more engaged in the lectures
because they knew that I
would test them in the end.
And these were tests that,
you know, meant nothing.
We don't get graded in
our fellowships very much.
And then the attending started.
My bosses started to
really get into it.
And they wanted to
participate, too.
And our nurses started
participating as well.
So I was generating
the questions,
and then I would send
it out to the team.
But then, they wanted the
opportunity-- you know,
I realized that the question
generation was probably the--
that's where sort of the most
bang for your buck came from.
So it's not
necessarily answering
other people's questions.
But I thought that, by me
creating a question, that's
really allowed me to sort
of distill the material
and make it my own.
So then I decided,
OK, for every lecture,
I will assign somebody
to generate questions
and then we'll distribute
it amongst ourselves.
So I took that a step further.
A few years ago, I got a HILT
Spark grant to actually create
an app to do this.
So the way that the app works is
that the learners can generate
questions and answers, and this
gets distributed through people
within the same course.
And so, not only do the students
get a benefit from generating
their own questions and
answers, which I think
is the best thing
about it, but then you
have this beautiful
question that you
can share with your colleagues.
And they can try to
answer your questions,
and also provide feedback on
that question saying, you know,
its a good question, though
I didn't understand this.
So it was a great tool,
and we sort of piloted
in the medical school
and learned a lot
about how students learn,
what they liked about the app,
what they didn't
like about the app.
And there were certainly some
things that we needed to fix.
And we actually got a second
HILT development grant
to sort of buff up the app
and make it even better.
But these skills of question
generation for your learners
doesn't require an app.
You can just get them
a note card, right?
At the end of class.
Is like, OK, write on the front
of the note card one question
that this presentation
brought up,
and then write down the answer.
And they get a
benefit from that,
and then they can share
that with their classmates.
And so that everybody--
sort of everybody wins.
So that's what I've been doing.
So stay tuned for the app.
The app is called Ask Up.
So it's out there
now, but it's--
we need to do some updates.
But hopefully, by
next year we'll
have a working up
that it's free to use.
And I would welcome use of the
app and in your classrooms.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much
to Emily and to John
for sharing some of
your experiences,
and how they really have had
an impact on your classroom
and on your students' learning.
Our hope for today is
that you can all come away
with some ideas for how you can
make small, targeted changes
to your teaching that are not
so big that you need to overhaul
your syllabus or have
that enormous feeling
of vulnerability that
we've often feel when we're
trying to make changes.
These are all things
that can be done
in a variety of
different class sizes,
and in a variety
of different times.
So oftentimes, less
than five minutes.
So this is when we get to the
mysterious cards on your table.
If you want to take a minute
and just turn over those cards.
We have another activity.
All right.
So there's a number
of different decks.
You can kind of
separate them out here.
And here's where
we are going to do.
Back in the icebreaker,
we asked you
to think about a challenge
or an opportunity for growth
and for change that you have
identified in your own course.
And Emily also
brought up this idea
of having an
adjective that of what
you want your course to be like.
And so what these cards
are are a way for you
to find ideas of solutions
to those challenges.
And what we want to do is-- in
a second we're going to ask you
all to stand up and walk
around the room again--
is find one or two solutions
in these cards that you think
might solve the challenges
that you've identified.
Or if you see one
that might work
for one of those people you were
talking to in the beginning,
you can grab a card for them to.
So you'll notice the
cards are divided
into different categories.
In our front three
tables here, we
have cards related
to active learning
and to what we call
mini experiences, which
are ways of taking an
experiential learning activity,
like a role play, and doing
it in a smaller form that
isn't so big to take on.
In our second row here,
the middle three tables,
we have cards that relate
to community building,
to icebreakers, which are really
a form of community building,
and also to small
group activities.
So if when you were listening
to Emily you were thinking, wow,
I really want to have some
ideas for how I can better
build community in my course
and get my students engaged
that way, those middle three
tables have ideas for you.
And then the back
three tables have
ideas for what we've called
a structured study, which
is, if the challenges
you're thinking about
are my students aren't getting
as much out of the reading
as I wish they were, I wish
they had more study skills
and more directed study
for outside of class,
there's ideas there.
Or what we call setting
the stage, which
is things you can do in the
first five minutes of lecture
to try to get your students
more involved and engaged,
and to activate
some of that recall.
So if what John was talking
about was appealing to you,
you want to head to
those back three tables.
So we will be--
your goal, find two cards.
You're going to have about
15 minutes to do this.
We're going to do the poll?
Yes.
And we are launching a
Poll Everywhere poll.
How many of you have ever
used Poll Everywhere?
All right, a number of you.
So what's going to happen?
Erin's going to pull
it up on the screen.
You use your cell
phone for this.
It will give you
a number to text,
and the message that
you're supposed to text.
So in this case, the phone
number that you text to
is 22333.
And you text that
phrase, HILT 2017.
And it will come back to you.
It will activate the poll.
And what we're
asking you to do here
is, if, as you're coming across
these cards, you see any ideas
that you might want to implement
or that you might have ideas
to adapt, you can text
your ideas to this poll,
and they'll all go
up on the screen
so we can all share them.
Everybody clear on
what we're doing?
So can I ask everyone
to make your way back
to your icebreaker group?
Because we're going to end with
an opportunity for everyone
to share with each
other ideas you
have had from
finding a card that
might apply to someone else's
opportunity for improvement,
or just whatever thought
that you might have had
as you look through the cards.
And as you're getting
there, I would just
like to mention a couple
of things about the cards.
So first of all, our
apologies for not already
having these available for
you to have as a digital copy.
That's something that we can
easily do and intend to do.
We just didn't get around to
it before the actual session.
So in some form in the
HILT conference follow up,
you will receive a link to
where you can get the PDF
and download all of these cards.
We'd like to also make
the template available so
that people can add.
There are many other
great ideas, obviously,
I think many of you are having
as you go around about things
that fit in these categories.
So we'll be doing that.
The second thing I
wanted to mention
is that the idea
with the cards was
that the little ones are easy
for you to pick up and take
along with you.
And you should
certainly feel free.
So take as many cards
as are sparking an idea
that you'd like to pursue.
So what we'd like to do
to finish off this session
is to have you continue
in the small groups
and speak with each
other about ideas
that you found interesting
and, perhaps, to have
a little opportunity
to recognize
the ways in which even
implementing these small ideas
is a little bit like
jumping off a cliff.
So thinking about
how they actually
function in the context
of your classroom.
Because, sometimes,
it's not quite as simple
as a little card makes it look.
So please, enjoy those
final conversations,
and this will be
the moment where
we thank you for your
participation in this session.
And let's just altogether give
ourselves round of applause,
and, particularly, our speakers.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]